okay so good afternoon everyone
my name is quinley and i'm from the
illinois institute of technology i'm
very glad to come here to the wolfram
technology conference and present
my study concert with my advisor dr ben
vavlid
and
today our topic is how does high
frequency treating affect low frequency
treating
and i believe some of you have already
heard of high frequency trading
but unfortunately until now the
the definition of high frequency trading
is still ambiguous
according to a 2010 report issued by the
u.s securities and exchange commission
the ussec
they listed a couple of characteristics
related to the high frequency trading
for example they characterized the high
frequency treating as a treat with the
use of high-speed and sophisticated
computer programs
and usually they treat they can
establish and liquidate the positions in
a very short time period
and by the end of the trading days they
won't carry their positions overnight
none of the existing study from academia
considered
how to how the hft affects their
counterparties
that is the low frequency treating
and
our study try to fill this gap
and we try to examine vessel or not the
hft benefits lft in terms of two
dimensions one is the liquidity and the
other one is the execution quality of
the low frequency trading
and as a further step
we examine the hft's intermediary effect
on
lft
we assume that the hft stands
in as a middleman between the
traditional market makers who was
usually in low frequency and the low
frequency traders
and they tried to take the liquidity in
the ones from the market makers and then
transport to the low frequency traders
who demand this liquidity
and at the beginning we want to
introduce the measures we use to
evaluate the liquidity
first we have the treat frequency
it represents
the number of
transaction messages
in one minute
and second we have the average size it
represents the average trade quantity
of per order among the others in the
same minute
and will also include the transaction
cost related measures
including the effective half spread
it is
and it is the difference between the
treated price
and
the midpoint of the code of the quoted
bit as
bit asker prices
and this effective half spread can be
decomposed into two components one is
called the realize the half spread
it is
it represents
the transaction cost components due to
the monopoly power and in our study this
monopoly power comes from
the market makers
and the other components is called the
price impact due to the adwords
selection and in our study this adwords
selection comes from the high frequency
traders
and in terms of the execution quality
side
we have three measures the first is the
average waiting time and the waiting
time is
the time
between
the submission of a limited order and
the finalization of the same order
and we'll also have
two ratios which
represents the likelihood of execution
the first one is the frequency ratio
it is the number of executed transaction
messages over the total transaction
messages added in the same minute
and likewise the quantity ratio of
execution
is
the quantity executed in one minute over
the total quantity the total quantity
and added in the same minute
okay next i want to talk about the data
we use
we used a very unique data set
including the dow jones industrial
average 30 stocks
and
it covers 134 trading days during
november 2010
and may 2011.
our data is microsecond timestamp
therefore we can observe each one
of the individual transaction messages
in our data set
and as the initial data process data
processing
we categorize our transaction messages
into three types of orders
and from the numbers here you can see
our study is a pure big data analysis
study
after the data processing we have
414 million
high frequency trading limit orders in
our data
and
107 million low frequency trading limit
orders in our data
and finally we have 54 million
low frequency trading market orders and
after categorizing them into three types
we group the other messages for each
type
by minute
so we have one 34 trading days and for
each trading day we have six hour and a
half as the trading period so as a total
we have 30 390
minutes for one single day
and then i want to move to the
to our analysis
in order to explore
the impact of hft on the low frequency
we include the different dimensions of
hft and different dimensions of hft
activity in our independent variable
group
so for the hft side we have the trade
frequency of hft calculated by the hft
limit orders the 440
limit orders
and we have the average quantity
category calculated by
the hft limit orders and we have the two
transactions
transaction cost components
the realized spread and the price impact
from the hiv side
and will also include three necessary
lft related measures
in our independent variable group
we have
the
effective half spread from the market or
from the low frequency market order side
and the two transaction components
from the lft limit order side
and in order to take a deep look at
the lft
activity
we have a total of seven dependent
variables
in our regression
and after categorizing them by the order
type
on the lft limit order side we have the
frequency the trade frequency and
average trade quantity
as the dependent variable
regarding
the
liquidity of lft limit orders
we have the average reading time
frequency ratio quantity ratio
from the lft limit order side
regarding the
execution quality of the lft limit
orders
and on the lft market order side we
include the treat frequency and average
treat quantity as a dependent variable
which can capture the liquidity of llt
lft market orders
so now let's move to the reload
so since we have dimensions of hft
related measures in our independent
variable group
we pick up the trade frequency of hft as
the representative to show you how it
affects
the
lft activity across the different
dimensions
and at first we can see
if the street frequency of hft
increases
it can help increase the trade frequency
of lft orders across the both type the
both the frequency of
limit order and the frequency of the
market order increases as well
and the same posit and the similar
positive relationship
appears
as well
on
the size of the lft orders in both type
when the treat frequency of hiv goes up
it helps increase the size of lft limit
orders and market orders both
and in terms of the execution quality of
the lft limit orders
when
the trade frequency of hft in the market
increases
it helps reduce the reading time of the
low frequency limit orders
and it's and it also help
increase
the likelihood of execution for the lft
limp orders
shown by the frequency ratio and the
quantity ratio
and for the other independent variables
from the hft side
they gave me the same kind
relationship like the frequency like the
trade frequency of hiv gave us here
in our initial analysis we have
confirmed that hft facilitates
the liquidity and execution quality of
lft
so as a second step we try to take a
deep look
by discovering
the position the real position and
function
of the hft in the market
so we move to the intermediary effect of
hft and here we take the lft limit
orders as
the
as an example
and we know in the old time
when there were no hft
high frequency traders in the market
there were only market makers
who used to be
the liquidity provider to the low
frequency traders
and in our analysis
we used
the realized spread calculated from the
limit orders
to capture the direct cost to lft due to
the market makers
and after and after the high frequency
high frequency trader came out
we use
the adwords selection the price impact
calculated from the low frequency
trading limit order
to evaluate the direct cost to lft due
to hft
and we hypothesize that
the hft stand
in the middle between the market makers
and low frequency traders and they take
the liquidity in advance from the market
makers and then transport to the lower
frequency traders when they demand for
the liquidity
so
from the high frequency trader
standpoint
they have
they have a direct transaction cost
due to market makers represented by the
real license spread calculated from the
high frequency traders
limit order data
and
for the remaining component transaction
cost component the price impact
it evaluates the direct cost to hft due
to the competition against market makers
displayed and represented by the dash
dashed arrow in our figure
so
if
this transaction cost component
gets bigger and bigger
it implies that it is more probable for
the hft
to
beat market makers down and take
their place
and become the liquidity provider to the
lfts
and here is our result
so at first if we take a look at the
bottom two variables
and we can see across all the five
dependent variables
related to
the lft limit orders
from the standpoint of lft
the cost due to hft which is the bottom
one
always has
a larger coefficient
than
the cost due to market makers which is
the one
above it
so it implies that
the hft
affects lft with larger impact than the
traditional market maker because the
price impact is the direct cost due to
hft and the realized spread is the
transaction cost due to market makers
so that means
from
the lft standpoint they are more
sensitive
to
the cost due to hft than the cost due to
l and due to market makers
and if we take a look at the upper two
variables
from the hft standpoint
we can see that at first
both
both
the course component help increase the
treat frequency and the two likelihoods
of execution
and then reduce the waiting time
so once again
from the second analysis
it also confirms that hft is benefiting
the lft's liquidity and execution
quality
rather than
hurt them
and if we compare
these two coefficients these two
variables coefficients across all the
five regressions
we will notice that the cost due to hft
the cost to hft due to the competition
which is the price impact
of hft
has
larger coefficients
than the cost due to market makers to
hft
so it implies that
it is more probable that
hft takes place
takes place takes place of the market
makers
and provide liquidity to the lft
and
hft
has become the primary liquidity
provider to
to the lft
instead of the market makers
okay in conclusion
from our study at first
we have found we have found that the
more hft activity
can really benefit the lft
they can bring more frequency
and larger size of orders
a higher likelihood of execution and
reduce the waiting time
and second
we also find that
the hft plays as an intermediary
in the market and help
the liquidity transportation to lft
the hft
improves
the liquidity and execution quality
and
moreover
the hft's intermediate effect has become
dominant
compared with the traditional market
makers in low frequency
okay thank you